[Music]
on this Wednesday night murder for hire
new accusations the Indian government
directed an assassination plot this one
on us soil India needs to take this
seriously how the case is linked to the
killing of a sick leader in
BC anxiety over the pause in fighting in
Gaza and the fate of the remaining
hostages as Palestinians freed from
Israeli detention describe their ordeal
they think that any pal inan who is
fighting for freedom is an enemy of the
Israelis compensation for Canadian news
agencies how much Google agrees to pay
Publishers and she's known as the mama
of housekeeping I've not woken up and
not wanting to come to work a New
Brunswick woman awarded for 52 years of
hard
work global national with Donna FZ good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a murder For Hire
plot in the United States that has ties
to the killing of a six separatist
leader in British Columbia us
prosecutors alleg an agent of the Indian
government directed one of its citizens
to hire a hitman to assassinate another
sick man in New York City that Hitman
turned out to be an undercover agent and
the man accused of hiring him nikil
Gupta is now in jail in the Czech
Republic pending extradition to the US
the indictment connects that case to the
murder of Canadian Hardeep Singh nider
he was shot and killed outside of gwara
in Suri BC in June and prime minister
Justin Trudeau publicly claimed the
Indian government was involved in his
death India called that absurd now this
us indictment appears to confirm
evidence of a global plot to silence and
kill vocal critics of the Indian
government Jackson Prasco has our top
story asking this the target of the
alleged plot is believed to be gatw sing
panu a Canadian Aman duel citizen who
India has designated a terrorist the
indictment alleges an Indian government
employee ordered panon assassination in
New York recruiting another Indian
national nikil Gupta to hire a hitman
that Hitman was an undercover officer
one day after the June murder of six
separatist leader hardip Singh ner in
British Columbia Gupta allegedly told
the Hitman there was now no need to wait
on the plot in New York explaining that
nider was also the Target and not to
worry because we have so many targets
the indictment alleges there were three
additional assassinations planned on
Canadian soil moninder Singh says he
along with ner and others were warned by
the RCMP last year their lives were at
risk if the US does have information uh
I hope they're sharing it with Canada
and then our hope there would be is
Canada sharing it with the appropriate
people that might be at risk here the
news coming out of the United States
further underscores what we've been
talking about from the very beginning
which is is that India needs to take
this seriously the Indian government
needs to work with us to ensure uh that
we're getting to the bottom of this
Canada has been on a diplomatic Island
since prime minister Trudeau went public
in September with explosive allegations
about Indian government involvement in
niger's Murder both Trudeau and US
President Joe Biden privately raised
concerns to Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi at the G20 the US and
India have since held repeated highlevel
talks on the matter while Canada has
seen its diplomats expelled from India
and Visa Services Frozen for 2 months
well clearly we uh expect more
cooperation on their part um and more
engagement on their part India now
claims to have launched an inquiry into
the matter in a statement a senior Biden
Administration official said that the US
will continue to expect accountability
from the government of India based on
the results of their investigation Donna
Jackson rco in Washington thanks in Gaza
there is no confirmation the sixday
pause in fighting will be extended any
further it is set to expire within hours
and with it the deal to release more
hostages held by Hamas today two D
citizen Russian Israelis were freed
followed late tonight by 10 Israelis and
four Thai citizens and in exchange 30
Palestinian detainees are expected to be
freed in the West Bank what happens next
though is unclear negotiations are
overshadowed by claims from Hamas that
the youngest hostage 10-month-old kafir
bibas along with his four-year-old
brother Ariel and their mother were all
killed in an Israeli air strike Israel's
military says it's working to confirm
that the US Secretary of State is about
to make his fourth visit to the region
since the War Began and says he will
work on extending the pause in fighting
and on a long-term plan for peace
Redmond Shannon
reports the sixth transfer of hostage is
on day six of the pause Russian citizens
mother and daughter aren tati and yena
tanov released first Hamas says as a
tribute to Vladimir Putin for his
support the release of 10 more Israelis
and four Thai citizens coming later in
the night allowing for the next 30
Palestinian prisoners to go free too the
stalled swap intertwined with the
uncertainty over the truce intense
negotiations are taking place to prolong
the truce which we strongly welcome but
we believe we need a true humanitarian
ceasefire Qatar Egypt and the US have
been involved in talks to extend the
pause in fighting for a second time
means that more hostages would be coming
home more assistance uh would be getting
in so clearly that's something we want
uh and I believe it's also something
that that Israel
wants
Israeli leader Benjamin Netanyahu
continues to insist his forces will
return to fighting in Gaza without
explicitly saying when with time running
out for an extension of the ceasefire
The Times of Israel is reporting that a
senior Hamas official says there is
still no deal and that Hamas does not
find Israel's offer worth considering
the World Health Organization says the
Six-Day pause in fighting has helped it
transfer p patients and deliver medical
supplies but it says much more help is
needed in Gaza to deal with the
humanitarian crisis Dona all right
Redmond Shannon in London thank
you four people have been killed in
raids in the West Bank City of Janine
among them two boys aged 8 and 15 video
captured by security cameras shows
children running on the streets before
one of them falls to the ground Israel
says two senior Terror operatives as
they call them were killed in that those
raids the IDF says it Arrested 17 people
after searching houses and finding
weapons and ammunition Israel says it's
detain 2,000 suspects in the West Bank
since the attacks of October 7th the
military says it's part of a
counterterrorism operation against Hamas
though many people are being held
without charge Danielle hamam Jin
reports on what some of them are going
through and why the arrests appear to
have been ramped up in recent
days
once a week the messages are broadcast
from a radio station in the heart of the
West
Bank Their audience Palestinian inmates
held in Israeli
prisons this one is from a little girl
to her
aunt a mother to her son for the
Prisoners the radio is the only window
into the outside world everything else
has been
banned no TVs no letters and no visitors
allowed since October 7th when
Palestinians say prison conditions
deteriorated they say they were
subjected to beatings and abuse
19-year-old Sultan Saran was just
released as part of Israel's deal with
Hamas when he was four his father was
shot and killed by an Israeli
settler since then he's been arrested 24
times accused of throwing stones and
Molotov cocktails fish show
I've lost my childhood he says suan is
careful with his words his release like
everybody else's came with a
warning this is Israel's far-right
national security minister itamar benav
he banned Palestinians from celebrating
their release saying it was the same as
backing
terrorism some Palestinian leaders have
claimed that Israel spent the last 7
weeks arresting as many people as
possible preparing for hostage prisoner
exchange according to authorities in the
West Bank more than 3,000 Palestinians
are being held indefinitely without
knowing the charges against them talk to
me about administrative detention
yeah it is it is a an Emergency
law uh from
1945 unfortunately we are in the 21th
century but there is a state called
Israel
the only state over the world uh acting
this primitive and racist
law among those who were held under
administrative detention until Tuesday
night was Ruba AI age
23 we visited her in her home the next
day Israeli police barged in here at 300
in the morning when they arrested her
last month her crime according to
Israeli authorities involvement in a
far-left University Association deemed
unlawful and throwing
stones they think that any Palestinian
who is fighting for Freedom who is
fighting for dignity is an enemy of the
Israelis she says Ruba Israeli forces
told her was a threat to the public
though the majority of those released
hadn't been charged some were they were
tried and convicted but some also died
in Israeli detention at least six in
just under 50 days
according to Palestinian officials Donna
Danielle Hamin in Jerusalem
thanks a little later I speak with
Israeli author and journalist Gideon
Levy about how long he thinks the pause
between Israel and Hamas can last and
whether there is any path to peace the
federal government and Google have
struck a deal to pay news organizations
for their content Google will contribute
Millions to Canadian news Publishers and
drop its plan to ban Canadian news
content Mackenzie gray explains the
agreement and what it could mean for
online news in the long term after
months of negotiations finally an
agreement on the online news act Google
will be compensating our news
organization with $100 million annually
the search engine will negotiate with
one entity on behalf of all Canadian
media companies to split up the $100
million but that figure is well short of
the 172 million the Liberals had
previously said Google would pay
Canadian news organizations including
Global News in exchange for Content
being posted on their platforms the fact
that there's going to be one negotiator
on this this is actually pretty good
because this me of the kingstone week
the the newspaper in Victoria Island all
of these guys are now going to be
represented Google had previously warned
it would block Canadian news if the law
was not changed but the company backed
down from that stance saying they'll
continue to send valuable traffic to
Canadian Publishers what this uh money
from Google would help to do is to help
to infuse some money back into the news
industry in Canada meta the parent
company of Facebook and Instagram has
followed through in a newsband to avoid
having to be forced to pay media
companies negotiations to lift it have
stalled it's on Facebook to explain why
they're leaving their platform to
disinformation and misinformation meta
and Google dominate the Canadian
advertising landscape with 80% market
share that cuts into media companies
revenues leading to widespread layoffs
across Canadian journalism It's been a
disaster really um and it's less of a
disaster now but the former Vice chair
of the crtc believes this deal will at
best only slowed down further Cuts 100
million bucks is nothing to sneeze at
but in the larger when you look at the
entire industry overall it's not a heck
of a lot of money which organizations
get what money is still to be negotiated
through regulations but Peter men's
expects CBC and Radio Canada will be the
biggest beneficiaries to go on top of
their $1.2 billion government SI subsidy
McKenzie gray Global News
Ottawa the prime minister is plummeting
popularity coming up why insiders say he
doesn't want to quit
now there is a new snapshot of how
voters are feeling about Federal
politics these days an ipsos poll done
for global news shows the conservatives
lead the Liberals by 16 points if a
federal election were held today 40% of
those poed said they would vote
conservative 24% liberal 21% NDP those
numbers would point to a conservative
majority David Aken digs a little deeper
into the
[Applause]
numbers when the Liberals vaulted from
third to 1 in the 2015 election it was
all because of Justin Trudeau a leader
that Canadians were excited about after
nearly nine years of Steven Harper but
after 8 years of Justin Trudeau there's
no excitement left and liberal numbers
are plummeting Justin Trudeau for the
very longest time made them strong he
lifted up everybody uh but now he's
actually sinking everybody 72% of
respondents said Trudeau should step
down now even among those who are
liberal supporters 33% think Trudeau
should go I've never seen a number that
high for a prime minister probably in
since Brian Mor uh back in 9192 and that
that's what this really reminds me of
the right honorable Prime min
Trudeau himself knows these numbers do
not look good but Global News can report
Trudeau has told Close Associates he
would not be true to himself if he quit
as leader that he's looking forward to
taking on Pierre POV in the next
election and with two years until that
happens Trudeau and his team believe
they can turn the party's fortunes
around as a team we are all 100%
committed to supporting the Prime
Minister thank you Mr Speaker I tourism
Minister soraa Martinez farata was
recently named co-chair of the liberal
campaign she thinks Trudeau can do it
he's a fighter he's always been a
fighter is one of the great campaigners
that I've met in my life and I would not
underestimate him uh him on the next
campaign but Martina fata says the
party's messaging will change others not
just Trudeau will be involved selling
the liberal brand the new housing
Minister Sean Fraser for example is one
of those being featured more right now
meanwhile this fall for the first time
since trudo became leader a decade ago
the liberal party is running paid
negative ads attacking the conservatives
that is a clear recognition by the party
that even as they try to pull their own
numbers up by featuring less Trudeau
they have to pull down the conservative
numbers by focusing more on paev Donna
all right David Aken in Ottawa thanks
Israel's endgame ahead can it save all
the hostages and eliminate
Hamas
[Music]
for 54 days questions about how Israel's
war on Hamas will end have lingered a
Six-Day pause in the fighting and the
exchange of hostages for Palestinian
detainees has gone on with only minor
hitches but the fate of the remaining
hostages the future of Palestinians
living in Gaza and whether there is any
path to peace hang in the
balance Gideon Levy is an Israeli
journalist and author and he's with me
from Tel Aviv tonight Mr Levy thanks for
speaking with us you know the whole
world is watching this hostage drama the
joy of the families who have had their
loved ones come back to them the agony
of those who are still waiting the calm
in Gaza after weeks of bombardment but
how long do you think this pause in
fighting will last that's a that's the
question right now I believe it will
last for few more days and then will be
the real challenge when we will finish
with is releasing all the women the
children the elderly people and we'll
get to the core of the hostages namely
the soldiers because then the price will
be quite high and I wonder if this
right-wing government of Israel will be
ready to pay this price and if not what
will be the alternative so very soon we
will reach to a point in which Israel
will have to make its choice either
releasing hostages or going for war this
will be the the naked choice in a way I
suppose you're saying sacrifice the
hostages yes I can't see it happening
because the national sentiment is right
now really focused on releasing the
hostages but in the same time people
want more war against
Kamas they have they have to choose
finally it will not go hand to hand it
will have to be a very clear choice
between the two this exchange as you
know so far has involved Only Women and
Children held hostage roughly 10 A Day
released for about 30 or so Palestinian
detainees being released again can you
explain how the dynamic might change if
all the women and children are
released yeah then we come to the
formula that Kamas suggested and there
will be no other formula everyone for
everyone namely all the rest of the
hostages for all the thousands of
Palestinian prisoners in Israel's
jailed the question is if Israel will be
ready to do so without it there will be
no release I mean they might find some
kind of interim stages but finally it
will be about this and that's that's
really a radical question you know
President Biden warned Israel at the
start of all this not to be consumed by
rage and risk repeating America's
mistakes after 911
do you think there is an end game
towards peace being worked on right now
there might be an end game in the white
house but there is no end game right now
in Jerusalem or for the sake in Gaza or
in ramala there are no partners for any
peace process right now there is no
visible plan and I am afraid that
although talking are just liap service
but nothing more than this you cannot
have a um peace process with those
actors and with those plans I mean with
whom with Hamas with the Palestinian
Authority which is totally paralyzed
with the most right-wing nationalistic
government that Israel have ever had
with whom exactly all right Israeli
journalist and author Gideon Levy in
telie thank you thank you for having
me next Decades of hard work recognize
the award for this hotel
housekeeper there are so many people in
this country who work hard and never get
the recognition they deserve Nancy Pon
started working as a hotel housekeeper
when she was 16 and 52 years later she's
not only still keeping it clean she just
won the Canadian tourism association's
employee of the year award Shelley
Steves has her story
it's a familiar sound that's been
echoing through the halls of this New
Brunswick hotel for more than half a
century how SK the knock of a humble yet
meticulous woman can we just fix the bed
with big standards and an even bigger
heart I've not woken up and not wanting
to come to work at the Crown Plaza Lord
Beaverbrook in fton Nancy peton is known
as the mama of housekeeping it is my mom
thank you it's been her job to make sure
the rooms are spotless for the last 52
years if we didn't maintain it they
wouldn't stay here and that
long-standing dedication to the hotel
guests and especially to her staff has
earned her tourism Canada's employee of
the year award that doesn't happen to
people like me yeah I'm so proud now
Nancy is not a woman who loves the
spotlight if I can help them I help them
however I can at 68 years old one would
think she would be ready to turn in her
room keys I don't think about retirement
that's because she's still channeling
her energy to make sure that everything
is just so everybody's hands are on the
remote control everybody including mine
right now so you'll clean it again yeah
Shelly Steves Global News frederickton a
lot of congrats Nancy that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
freezen tonight's here Canada is Lake
Louise in B National Park Alberta thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]